außerirdisches leben möglicherweise ist
es uns menschen ähnlicher als gedacht
einige wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler sind davon überzeugt
dass es da draußen in den unendlichen
weiten des kosmos erdähnliche welten
gibt und auf denen soll
menschenähnliches leben existieren quad
allerdings ist die gravitation größer
oder schwächer dürften sich die aliens
deutlich von uns unterscheiden also wie
sehen sie jetzt ausblicks um science
news dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
alleine in unserer milchstraße unserer
galaxie könnten schätzungen zufolge
alleine hartung
10.000 außerirdische zivilisation
existieren mittlerweile sind sich die
meisten fachleute sicher wir sind
keineswegs alleine im weltall doch wo
genau hält sich außerirdisches leben
versteckt und vor allem wie können wir
uns außerirdische wesen vorstellen in
der science fiction literatur und den
filmen sind es oft naja grüne männchen
manche stellen sich aber auch in
sektenartige monster oder körperlose
lichtwesen vor wenn sie an aliens denken
doch wie realistisch sind diese
vorstellungen von außerirdischen fest
steht die wissenschafts community sucht
beispielsweise auf dem mars er nach
kleins lebewesen mikroben doch es gibt
auch einige forschende die noch ein
stück weiter gehen sie gehen davon aus
dass es im kosmos leben gibt das uns
menschen sehr viel ähnlicher ist als wir
bislang denken hat sich da draußen also
menschenähnliches leben entwickelt
welche theorien gibt es dazu und sie
könnte es aussehen die antworten auf all
diese spannenden fragen gibt es jetzt
hier bei klicks und salz in future die
astrobiologie weltweit steht vor vielen
ungelösten rätseln zum einen wird in
dieser disziplin versucht
rahmenbedingungen einzugrenzen unter
denen außerirdisches leben aller
wahrscheinlichkeit überhaupt entstehen
kann eine weiterführende super spannende
frage ist dann welche formen von
lebewesen unter diesen verschiedenen
bedingungen entstehen und sich
entwickeln können fest steht die
grundlegenden bausteine des lebens sind
sogar in großer menge im all vorhanden
die rede ist von sauerstoff stickstoff
wasserstoff und kohlenstoff kometen sind
voll damit schon seit längerer zeit im
visier der forschende nähert artige
planeten die ihren stern innerhalb
dessen lebensfreundlichen zone umkreisen
unter fachleuten auch als sogenannten
habitablen zone bezeichnet gemeint ist
damit die abstands region in der ein
planet einem stern umkreisen muss damit
gemäßigte temperatur möglicherweise die
existenz von flüssigem wasser erlauben
denn dass die zumindest bei dem leben
das wir auf der erde kennen als
grundvoraussetzung dafür dass es
existieren kann doch entdeckung auf der
erde offenbar immer wieder dass es viele
widerstandsfähige lebensformen gibt die
in wirklich lebensfeindlichen
bedingungen überleben egal ob in
bitterer kälte großer hitze oder
gesättigter salzsäure und solche
extremen orte auf der erde sind durchaus
vergleichbar mit die bedingungen auf
fremden himmelskörper dazu die
us-wissenschaftler da er in norfolk je
mehr wir über die vielfalt des lebens
auf der erde lernen desto mehr erweitern
wir unsere definition des lebens und sie
ist in scheinbar feindlichen umwelt und
existieren kann doch wie können wir uns
außerirdisches leben vorstellen für die
fachwelt ist eine sache klar egal wie
ein organismus aufgebaut ist er wird
definitiv an seine jeweilige umwelt
angepasst sein sein aussehen seine
lebensweise und seine physiologie also
wird passend zu seinem lebensraum sein
der lebensraum vom quasi die
verschiedenen spezies heißt also auch im
umkehrschluss je mehr infos wie über die
heimat potenzieller außerirdische haben
umso besser können wir auch deren
merkmale und charakteristischer
vorhersagen bis zu einem gewissen grad
natürlich könnte also auf einem
erdähnlichen planeten auch
menschenähnliches leben entstanden sein
genau davon gehen einige forschende
weltweit aus so auch der britische
paläontologe zusammenkommen bei morris
der primaten ähnliche zweibeinige aliens
für sehr wahrscheinlich hält denn seiner
meinung prägt die umwelt das leben und
die evolution sehr deutlich bei
eigentlichen umweltbedingungen sollte es
demnach also gut möglich sein dass sich
zweibeinige primaten als eine
intelligente dominante art auch anderswo
im kosmos durchgesetzt haben die
anhängerinnen und anhänger dieser idee
berufen sich dabei auf die sogenannte
konvergente evolution ähnliche merkmale
haben sich hierbei nicht verwandten
arten im laufe der evolution entwickelt
eine unabhängig voneinander entstanden
eine parallelentwicklung durch anpassung
an ähnliche umweltbedingungen
beispielsweise so sehen sich haie und
der schiene mit ihrem
stromlinienförmigen körpern ziemlich
ähnlich nicht verwunderlich schließlich
wollen sich beide möglichst schnell
durchs wasser bewegen können dennoch
haie und delfine sind alles andere als
verband delfine sind säugetiere und
teuer sind fische und auch bei tieren
die auf dem land leben gibt es solche
sogenannten konvergenzen dazu der
britische biologe jackpot einiges hat
sich auf der erde viele male entwickelt
die herzen augen der segmentierte
gliedmaßen heißt also segmentierte
gliedmaßen und augen sind wichtig um
sich an land zu bewegen weiß hat sich
deswegen auf der erde vielfach
unabhängig voneinander entwickelt augen
möglicherweise bis zu 40 mal ein
weiteres beispiel die vor der
extremitäten von maulwurfs grillen und
maulwürfen die eine ähnliche form
aufweisen beide tierarten haben sich
damit an das graben im erdreich
angepasst dabei unterscheiden sich die
grund bauplänen der tiere deutlich
maulwürfe verfügen über ein internes
skelett insekten dagegen über ein
exoskelett auch das fliegen hat sich auf
der erde wohl alleine viermal unabhängig
voneinander entwickelt war insekten
flugsauriern fledermäusen und vögeln
doch warum sollte solch eine
parallelentwicklung lediglich auf der
erde stattfinden
auch auf erdähnlichen planeten ist solch
eine konvergente evolution vorstellbar
so die meinung einiger
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
das leben auf einem fernen er zwilling
wäre ähnlichen ökologischen chemischen
und physikalischen bedingungen
ausgesetzt das leben auf einem
erdähnlichen planeten würde sich demnach
also auch er ähnlich entwickeln
menschenähnliche außerirdische während
somit gut denkbar diese meinung vertritt
eben auch samen kommen wie er sagt in
einem interview mit dem bbc silence
focus magazin die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass ich etwas analoges zur entwicklung
eines menschen entwickelt ist wirklich
ziemlich hoch da bin ich mir sicher und
angesichts der anzahl potentieller
planeten von der wir guten grund zu der
annahme haben dass sie existieren führt
dies zu einer sehr großen anzahl von
intelligenten die uns wahrscheinlich
ähnlich sind und seinem comeback steht
nicht alleine da mit seiner meinung dass
sich außerirdisches leben auf ähnliche
weise entwickelt haben könnte wie wir
menschen auch der us biologe ericsson
baum geht davon aus dass uns
außerirdisches leben ähnlicher sein
könnte als man bislang dachte in einem
interview mit dem quantum magazin sagt
er dazu da die evolution über alte
erklärungs mechanismus für das leben ist
sollten die prinzipien die wir auf der
erde entdecken auf den rest des
universums anwenderseite auf einem eher
zwilling also wäre es dieser theorie
zufolge beispielsweise extrem
unwahrscheinlich dass außerirdische
lebewesen zusätzliche augen oder
gliedmaßen besitzen denn das würde nur
sinn machen wenn es ihnen in ihrer
umwelt vorteile bringen würde würde es
aber auf einem erdähnlichen planeten
eben nicht und so sind auf einem
erdähnlichen planeten tatsächlich
humanoide oder insektizide varianten
sehr wahrscheinlich auf einer super erde
oder einem anderen größeren planeten
dagegen müsste sich dieser theorie
zufolge müssen sich organismen
entwickelt haben die stabil gepanzert
sind eher groß und zudem auch extrem
kräftig ein grund die höhere schwerkraft
die diese wesen sonst zerquetschen oder
an der fortbewegung in dann würde auch
herzen und kreislaufsystem dieser aliens
müssten daran angepasst sagt mehr kraft
und benötigt um das blut in höhere
gelegene körperteile zu befördern
möglicherweise würde solch ein alien auf
vier beinen oder sogar noch mehr laufen
und sich lang gestreckt über den boden
bewegen die tausendfüßler beispielsweise
denn in kürze die entfernung zum boden
desto kleiner die verletzungsgefahr
welche lebewesen könnten sich demnach
auf einen masse und granaten wie etwa
dem mars entwickeln diese außerirdischen
wesen wären wohl eher schmächtiger und
zierlicher als wir menschen wenn es sie
denn dann gibt doch es gibt auch
fachleute die diese idee der
konvergenten evolution im gesamten
kosmos abwegig finden so zum beispiel
der bereits verstorbenen us
evolutionsbiologisch stephen jay gould
er vertrat die meinung dass evolution
durch zufällige genetische mutationen
vorangetrieben wird zufällige
umwelteinflüsse haben einen weiteren
einfluss darauf er nennt hier das
beispiel des massen aussterbens also was
meint ihr ähnlich oder vollkommen anders
wie sehen aliens aus schreibt es in die
kommentare
ich mische mich dort dann auch ein und
schaut das nächste video aliens im
fadenkreuz projekt galileo sucht gezielt
nach außerirdischen super spannendes
projekt also anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran